hey in this video we'll be talking about
the enzymes which are frequently used in
recombinant DNA technology so what comes
in your mind when you hear the term
recombinant DNA technology definitely
cutting and pasting the DNA having
plasmids changing the chromosome
sequence gene sequence etc right and all
of these things that we talked about
requires enzymes like which are Caesars
or enzymes which are like glues etc
right so in this video we would talk
about several such enzymes which are
absolutely essential for the recombinant
DNA technology and these enzymes that we
are going to talk about today our day to
day used in a molecular biology lab and
they're super important for molecular
biology and biotechnology we're going to
talk about restriction endonuclease t4
DNA ligase cleaner fragment alkaline
phosphatase reverse transcriptase and
also micro cockle nucleus RNA is a DNA's
1 and RNase H so all of these enzymes we
are going to learn about in this
particular video so stay tuned and the
end of this video it's a quick
bird's-eye view to all of these enzymes
first let's talk about the restriction
in the nucleus enzymes if you remember
the workflow of cloning first we have
two restriction digest our vector or the
plasmid so the restriction in the
nucleus would work like a molecular
Caesar right then our chain of interest
is also cleaved with the same
restriction enzyme followed by a
ligation step and then it is transformed
into the bacteria as the bacteria grow
our gene of interest also grows with
them that is why restriction
endonuclease could be considered as the
molecular Caesar which would be used to
cut a particular segment of DNA
specifically now why the hell the
restriction enzymes were isolated from
bacteria why to the bacteria we need the
restriction endonuclease machinery right
if it has to weave the DNA so scientists
really scratched their heads for a long
time letting the figure out that the
restriction enzymes
the bacteria like e-coli a protection
against such infections no fudge are the
biggest enemies for the bacteria
restriction endonuclease can recognize
fudge DNA and selectively cut them and
destroy them
but it does not recognize its own DNA
and cut it because eco lies own DNA is
methylated at specific residues which
prevent the restriction in the nucleus
enzyme to engage to its own DNA and
cleave it and that is how this
sophisticated machinery came into the
light of molecular biology and it is now
utilized to cut the gene of our own
interest so there are several type of
restriction restriction endonuclease
enzymes that are now discovered among
them the type 2 restriction endonuclease
are the most important equal one family
to one entry these are the type 2
restriction endonuclease now these type
2 in the nucleus are so important in
case of biotechnology because they
really have a specific recognition site
so they don't cut in on specifically
other two restriction endonuclease type
type 1 and type 3 they do cut DNA but
cut at a random site from a random place
neared our recognition site so they are
not so specific for our purposes in
terms of recombinant DNA technology type
2 restriction enzymes are of our
interest now restriction enzymes can cut
and have different restriction patterns
it can produce a sticky end which has
like overhangs which are easy to like it
and their blunt ends which tool doesn't
have any overhang now next thing that we
are going to talk about this after the
restriction which in logically comes is
ligation so the ligation enzyme is
generally isolated from t4 fudge and it
is called t4 DNA ligase t4 DNA ligase
with the help of ATP dntps and magnesium
ion it can like it the broken
or like it to the vector with the insert
and that is how the DNA ligase work so
DNA like this actually forms the
phosphodiester bond between the
juxtaposed iframe phosphate of one
strand to the 3 prime hydroxyl terminus
of another strand that is how the
phosphodiester last phosphodiester bond
is created by DN elias now it is used in
molecular biology heavily for cloning
but at the same time we have to
understand in molecular biology itself
in the replication process cells use
like years to prepare the Okazaki
fragments remember right now we move
quickly to a version of TNA polymerase
which is known as DNA polymerase cleaner
fragment DNA polymerase cleaner fragment
is a big fragment of the DNA polymerase
when a chunk of the DNA polymer is one
now if we compare DNA polymerase 1 the
entire DNA polymer is 1 and the cleaner
fragment the thing that we refer
fragment doesn't have it's the
exonuclease activity in the forward
direction that means 5 prime to 3 prime
exonuclease activity 5 prime to 3 prime
exonuclease activity is pretty
problematic and that's why it is not
appropriate for cloning and that's why
in order to get rid of that they
generated DNA polymerase 1 which is
devoid of this forward exonuclease
activity and that is now known as clean
a fragment clean a fragment has several
different usage in molecular biology
first and foremost it is used to prepare
radioactive DNA probes otherwise it is
super important in terms of plant and
cloning filling 3 payments or blunting
the Phi prime overhangs it is super
important so let's look at it quickly so
let's say we have a vector cloning
vector which has a blunt end so we need
a blunt end insert as well because
otherwise if the insert is sticky and it
won't like it nicely so but the problem
is the insert that we have is basically
a sticky end so we need to plant it
somehow before we can clone or before we
can do the ligation reaction so how do
we blunt it now there could be two type
of overhang at 3-prime overhang at the
three prime site or a five-prime
overhang both the cases the DNA polymer
is one cleaner fragment would perform
its job now what would happen is it
would bind to the three prime overhangs
and with its Phi Prime with its 3 prime
to 5 prime exonuclease activity it would
resect the ends or otherwise it can bind
with the 5 prime over hand and then with
its 5 prime to 3 Prime polymerase
activity fill in the ends both the cases
it would create plantains and this blunt
end can nicely be cloned into the plant
and cloning vector and that can we
transformed in with normal protocol to
get recommendin colonies next we talk
about alkaline phosphatase and poly
nucleotide kinase both these enzyme are
used in a combination and both these
enzymes are super important component of
a day-to-day research in molecular
biology as the name suggests one enzyme
is a kinase type enzyme which helps in
phosphorylation and another is a
phosphatase enzyme which helps in
dephosphorylation so let's see how these
two opposing acting enzymes can be
useful for molecular biology so imagine
this is a plasmid and you restriction
digest the plasmid and after that what
happens you have the plasmid in a
restricted format but there in the ends
there are phosphate groups right it can
always rely get to each other and that's
a big problem you don't get recombinants
instead you get relegated products but
if you use the enzyme alkaline
phosphatase to chop off the phosphate
from the five prime ends what you would
have right now is only hydroxyl at the
end now with only hydroxyl at the end it
cannot rely get which is good right that
means only recombinant would be produced
or the probability of recombinant is
increased now let's say you have a PC
so from one particular region you have
amplified it but the ends doesn't have a
phosphate group right now so you need to
phosphorylate the end because otherwise
the ligation would always work at the
5-prime of the phosphate group and the
three prime hydroxyl group in between
that it would create the phosphodiester
bond so you need something to
phosphorylate the PCR product which is
generally done by pulling you to your
tight kinase and thereby
dephosphorylation the vector and
phosphorylating the insert really
increase the efficiency of the cloning
and that's how it is super important in
terms of cloning these days now it can
be also used for in labeling purposes or
labeling the DNA with radioactive probes
let's say so let's say here is a portion
of the DNA which we want to label we
first use alkaline phosphatase to d
phosphorylate the five prime ends or the
five prime phosphates
now we would reef already with poly
nucleotide kinase now using poly
nucleotide kinase we can reform it but
once we are using poly nucleotide kinase
we can give give
ready labelled nucleotides which would
incorporate the label inside the DNA and
the ends would be labeled right most of
the cases in order to incorporate a
radio label the radioactive ATP is used
and that is how the end of the DNA is
labeled by regulable p32 oftenly these
strategies used to make label probes for
RNA in situ hybridization or probes for
southern or northern blotting now next
let's talk about a micro kako nucleus
which is an MBO nucleus that
preferentially dices a single-stranded
DNA or RNA especially at 80 or au rich
regions so you can clearly understand in
order to get rid of single standard
products like be it our apo DNA from a
mixture of these things we can use this
particular micro Coco nucleus right now
that is how micro Coco's nucleus is
pretty handy ins I mean day to day
molecular biology research then comes
RNA is a
and this enzyme is not uncommon for us
RNA is a as the name suggests it would
cleave RNA from a solution right if you
have a solution which contains both DNA
and RNA
rnase would be totally degraded after
using RNA as a while the DNA the
double-stranded DNA are pretty much too
resistant now this kind of strategy or
rnase enzyme is mostly used mostly used
in case of plasmid isolations we'll
discuss about it let's quickly look at
how rnase aims and work
Irina's enzyme basically works by
cleaving the phosphodiester bonds in
between two nucleotides in the RNA it
forms a 2:3 cyclic nucleotide
intermediate and thereby breaking the
bond and freeing up a portion of the RNA
and that's how it works so we don't
focus on the mechanism in details but
let's just try to understand why it is
so important because let's say you have
isolated a plasmid right and you want to
do all the downstream processing of the
cloning from that particular plasma but
while isolating the plasmid from the
bacteria you don't need a contamination
of RNA in your sample so you want to get
rid of that RNA in order to get rid of
that RNA you can use rnase a enzyme
right similarly there is another cousin
of RNAs a which is known as RNase H
RNase H is pretty specific because it
can only target the RNAs which are in an
rna-dna hybrid format only it would
cleave the RNA in an rna-dna hybrid
format otherwise it won't click the RNA
so specially this is super important for
cDNA cDNA making to get rid of the
rna-dna hybrid now DNA's one as the name
suggests it gets rid of DNA
contamination from an RNA sample let's
say you have isolated an RNA sample from
a tissue and you want to do qPCR to
understand gene expression changes but
you don't need genomic DNA contamination
in that sample because while you make C
DNA from the extracted RNA the genomic
DNA contaminant can give rise to
nonspecific amplification that's why you
need to get rid of the
genomic DNA by DNA's and that would
ensure the only amplification that
happens happens from the cDNA not the
genomic DNA that would give you fruitful
results in your qPCR experiments next we
talk about reverse transcriptase which
is RNA dependent RNA polymerase so what
it would do is the reverse transcribe
the RNA it generally use a random exome
our primer or our live oddity primer and
using that it synthesize another strand
in this video will not talk about the
mechanism by which cDNA or synthesis
takes place but we know that reverse
transcriptase is super important to
create complementary DNA and it is super
important in the workflow of
transcriptomics so I hope you enjoyed
this video if you liked this video give
it a thumbs up don't forget to Like
share and subscribe thank you